cancer of the prostate is one of the
most common types of cancer in men in
most cases it developed slowly and many
men who can live with the disease for
decades without experiencing any
symptoms however if it's deemed to be
life threatening more invasive
interventions may be required a
long-standing therapy is to put
radioactive material inside the prostate
and kill the tumor this technique is
called brachytherapy the classic
approach is to implant a radioactive
seed into the prostate low dose rate or
permanent seed brachytherapy as it's
called delivers a steady dose of
radiation over the course of a few
months a newer approach is high dose
rate or temporary brachytherapy this
involves delivering radiation in short
bursts through thin tubes that are
temporarily inserted into the prostate
this enables the radiation dose to be
administered more quickly and more
accurately Becky therapy has a strong
track record but is falling out of use
in part this is due to doctors
increasingly deciding to employ active
surveillance and keeping an eye on lower
risk tumors through blood tests and
imaging rather than immediately
intervening but where treatment is
required many centres are opting either
for robotically assisted surgery or a
modern form of beam therapy called
intensity modulated radiation therapy
many oncologists are keen to ensure that
brachytherapy remains an option to
patients arguing that's in low-risk
cases of prostate cancer permanency
brachytherapy has been shown to stop the
cancer as effectively as robotic surgery
but at roughly half the cost and in
high-risk cases
combining temporary brachytherapy with
more aggressive beam therapy can
considerably delay cancer recurrence
compared to beam therapy alone
brachytherapy also comes with a
different side effect profile that some
patients may consider preferable for
instance surgery can lead to higher
rates of incontinence and sexual
dysfunction even several years after
treatment urinary tract obstruction is
more common with brachytherapy than both
surgery and beam therapy but in many
cases can be resolved so ensure
brachytherapy remains an option to men
who might benefit from it researchers
are trying to work out why it's fallen
out of favor and
for solutions some believe the technique
has an image problem brachytherapy might
be considered old-fashioned next to
robotic surgery and modern forms of beam
therapy a change of name to
interventional radio there opee has been
suggested to increase its allure but few
researchers have so far made the switch
there's also a financial element to
Brockie therapies full payment from
insurers and states health department's
to medical centers that perform
brachytherapy are often too low to cover
the cost of the treatment a tiered
funding system like that used in Spain
that takes into account the varying
complexity of brachytherapy could be
used as a model for others there are
also concerns that because of
brachytherapy z' decline there are fewer
opportunities for young doctors to learn
the technique to change that some groups
are establishing training initiatives
for doctors the American brachytherapy
Society for instance has set up a 10
year program to teach hundreds of
doctors how to perform these techniques
brachytherapy has a long history as a
cost effective treatment for prostate
cancer but whether or not patients will
continue to be afforded the opportunity
in the coming years remains to be seen
you